Ukraine has been making big advances in
the battlefield against Russia the
Ukrainian flag has been Flying high in
reclaimed territory and President
Vladimir zielinski visited some areas
where Russian troops had retreated
following these setbacks Russian
President Vladimir Putin escalated the
rhetoric on Wednesday
previously the Kremlin said that nuclear
weapons would be used only if Russia
faced an existential threat now they
said any attack on its territory could
generate that kind of a response Putin's
nationally televised speech Drew
condemnation from some world leaders at
the United Nations General Assembly
Putin claims he had to act
because Russia was threatened
but no one threatened Russia it seems
like the U.S and Western countries will
continue their tough approach toward
Russia and aren't going to be backing
down so here's what the West might do
next and Russia's challenges as the war
grinds on in Ukraine
[Music]
after Putin's speech protests broke out
in multiple Russian cities and
authorities detained nearly 1 000 people
the public outcry was sparked by his
call to mobilize as many as 300 000
reservists Putin is looking at only a
partial mobilization because of full
mobilization in a full War risks
creating unpopularity and could even
endanger his rule at some point in the
future so he's trying to strike a
balance between escalating the war and
not doing anything that's too unpopular
with the Russian people the mobilization
order speaks to what Russian political
analysts describe as Putin's tactic to
double down and take risks when facing
setbacks one of the challenges for
Russia will be to integrate any new
Personnel from the military mobilization
into the Fighting Force into brigades
into forces that can succeed in Ukraine
whether they'll succeed in that is a big
question Russian officials have also
recently announced plans to hold votes
to Annex four occupied regions in
Ukraine's east and south greetings to
all people at the U.N on Wednesday the
Ukrainian president called the
referendums a sham
and received the standing ovation after
his speech the crime was committed again
their values that make you and me a
community of the United Nations
and Ukraine demands punishment for
trying to steal our territory not all
world leaders at the Gathering voiced
full support for Ukraine in their
speeches Cuba conduct Western sanctions
on Russia while Iran blamed the U.S for
the situation in Europe as far as the
West goes the next steps are decisions
about whether to stay the course on
Ukraine to double down and keep
supporting Ukraine with weapons and
other types of intelligence support
along with reiterating their support
some Western governments have called
Russia's moves a sign of weakness and a
failed strategy the United States wants
this war to end
on just terms on terms we all signed up
for
that you cannot seize a nation's
territory by force there may be a
situation where some countries in the
west or some countries around the world
will be a little bit wary about
escalating a conflict some countries
could withhold military hardware this
kind of concern could make politicians
and their constituents think twice about
supplying so many Advanced weapons in
Ukraine